paid zero percent taxes on 56 of my  income last year and it's not how you  expected it so rather than have some  fancy trust set up or anything like that  if you own a business and you can  increase the profit of that business  let's say by 20 then there's going to be  a multiple that's applied to the value  of the business if i get an increase of  two million dollars in income from my  business that would actually increase my  value of my business by 10 million the  value of the business that was increased  is tax-free what i got taxed on is just  the income that i took from the business  it really doesn't matter what tax  jurisdiction you're in the richest  people in the world many of them live in  the highest tax jurisdiction it's  because they know that you don't get  rich off of the income but offer the  growth of the equities that always grows  tax-free